welcome back everyone it's Charlie big
surprise they dropped a brand new
official Boys season 2 trailer video so
we'll break it down there's a whole
bunch of new footage a bunch of Easter
eggs and there's a couple really big new
characters that they're bringing from
the comics to season 2 so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos I'll be doing videos
for season 2 just like I did them for
season 1 we also kind of know when it's
going to premiere so I'll explain that
at the end of the video too we start
with an opening shot of homelander
doing his Superman thing floating down
this is a very Superman esque shot he
was originally created to be a dark
parody of Superman just like the 7 is
meant to be a dark parody of the Justice
League or the Avengers but he slowly
floats down his face covered,
with a very strange look on his face
it's almost like he's going aw shucks
like he's not sad about something more
surprised in a caring way but he cares
deeply about the thing that he's looking
on the interesting thing that they do
with homelander in this trailer is
that most of the footage is just him in
and around his son which I think
obviously makes sense because they left
off on a cliffhanger at the end of
season 1 with him meeting his son for
the first time your mommy didn't tell
you I'm also your father everybody make
all the Darth Vader Luke Skywalker jokes
that you want I do think they're going to
be a lot of jokes about that during the
season you even see the severed hand
that Hughie is holding later in the
trailer so make even more Star Wars
Empire Strikes Back jokes you see the
two of them standing on top of the roof
of his mother's house as if he's getting
ready to teach him how to fly maybe
something just goes really bad with that
because his son is only half super they
play it really fast and loose about what
he's capable of passing on in terms of
abilities to his offspring it might wind
up being a Superman Conner Kent
situation where his little Superboy son
only gets some of the powers that he has
not everything we already know that he
has heat vision just like he does
because his eyes light up red when he's
staring into homelander's eyes but like
a really good example is the Conner Kent
can't fly like Superman flies he does
have a version of tactile Kinesis that
lifts him off the ground but it's not
flying in the traditional sense there's
a bunch of new footage of the female
acclimating way more to life out of
captivity talking to Frenchy here with a
shiny new bejeweled set of brass
knuckles that say bossy there's also a
scene of them run
out of a hospital with a security guard
this had his head ripped completely open
with them wearing these same outfits so
it's probably connected to this scene
speaking of people getting ripped apart
or blown up there's a bunch of footage
with people exploding for crazy reasons
like there's this restaurant scene with
a person from Vaught from last season
that got fired because of all the
Starlight stuff
she's screaming because somebody just
explodes inside this bard splatters
against the window you see all these
other normal people flailing around in
the mess that's left after there's
another scene in a separate place with
somebody getting splattered against a
window and then a whole bunch of black
noir just opening up ripping through
tons of people I know so many people
were excited to see him go crazy during
season one and they completely
downplayed his character there was the
brief scene with him fighting the female
just to show you how badass she was but
without getting into super spoilers or
anything like that he does have a lot of
secret super abilities that he just
hasn't shown you yet they just been
completely selling him as one character
when really he's a completely different
person the thing about black noir in the
comics though is that they've changed a
couple things about the way he's
portrayed on the TV show the actor in
real life who plays that character on
the TV show is an african-american but
in the comics it's a very different
character that's black noir underneath
that mask so unless there's some big
twist
I'm not expecting it to be completely
like the black noir comic book arc for
everyone that's read the comic book
please don't post spoilers about black
noir in the comments Frenchy looking
like he's rigging a bomb to what seems
like milk bottles like baby's milk
bottles Mother's Milk is also one of the
boys but in the comics drinking his
mother's milk gives him a measure of
super strength but they didn't really
include that in season one so I don't
know if it's going to be a theme during
season two but later I love this is so
funny and creepy at the same time you
see homelander drinking some milk from that bottle in the creepiest way
possible I'll give you one guess what
kind of milk that is given his mommy and
daddy issues talk about creepy rejected
got milk ads there's butcher lining up a
sniper shot Huey Frenchie and mother's
milk it was seems like a camp site so
maybe this is them just doing some boys
group training out in the field the way
they cut this scene of homelander at a
press conference and then the female
right after him implies that they're
hyping up
sort of homelander versus the female fight which seems like a natural progression
given how powerful she is she's not a
strong as homelander but of all the
boys she's currently got the best shot
at hurting him homelander is capable
of being injured it's just it has to be
someone stronger than homelander or
someone using a weapon that's stronger
than homelander and there's only three
or four people in the comics that are
capable of doing that and we've only met
about half of those people already
stormfront is one of the big new
characters that is almost as powerful as
homelander not quite as strong but
still one of these strongest superheroes
on the planet so I'll explain that
character in a second because she does
not appear during this trailer and they
made a couple of changes to the comic
book version of the character the deep
is back he still looks like he's living
in disgrace out in Ohio remember Vaught
kicked him out of the seven and banished
him for all that bad press they didn't
care about the dead dolphin during that
botched save and they didn't care about
the harassment charges from
starlight they cared about the bad PR so
they're like okay you're done you're
going to go and live in Ohio off in
obscurity for a little while so
everybody will kind of forget about what
you just did there's this weird shot of
black noir in the suburbs looking like
he's staking someone out on top of
someone's roof this might be him
stalking homelander in his son keeping
tabs on them for Vaught Queen Maeve is at this urban disaster
starlight looks like she's
starting to enjoy all the fame and
attention her slutty looking new costume
doesn't bother her that much anymore the
way they shoot her with Queen Maeve's
picture right next to her and then she
kind of turns her head with all the
cameras makes it seem like they're
implying some kind of conflict between
the two of them over star lights rising
popularity but I think that's a big
misdirect because in the comics Queen
Maeve also wants to help out the boys
because she thinks that homelander in
the stuff that the seven and Vawter
doing is just as terrible as everyone
else they bring back Giancarlo Esposito
'he's character from season one he's
probably one of the new Vaught
characters that's taking the place of
what Stilwell used to do during season
one because remember he was stillwell's
boss at Vaught he was more concerned
with their plans to get supers in the
military and eventually the government
so which is the natural escalation the
boss behind the boss is now making
himself more known if you're a big fan
of the Mandalorian TV series everybody
loves baby Yoda of course but Giancarlo
Esposito is playing a
former imperial moff who probably won't
debut till towards the end of that
series so if you are a big fan of his
he'll be doing really cool stuff on the
mandalorian really soon to love the shot
of homelander coming to hang out with
his son randomly in butcher's wife or
former wife answering the door like oh
crap now I have to deal with this
again the boys go boating for
some reason it seems like they're
chasing someone this would be one of the very few times that the deep is actually
useful anytime the adventure takes place
on water really excited about this scene
of butcher versus black noir remember
he's not only badass at martial arts it
also seems kind of like he has a measure
of super strength too then homelander
just choking the crap out of starlight
in this elevator then they're just a
parade of middle fingers from the female
Queen Maeve and homelander walking out
of a building implying that season two
will just be more of everyone hating on
homelander so as far as I could tell
if there's no new footage of storm front
in this trailer and I didn't see anyone
that looked like tech Knight but he
could also be a bigger part of season 2
just because he's such a big part of the
next part of the story that they're
doing from the comics storm front is
supposed to be the original superhero on
planet earth created during World War
two by Nazi scientists when they came up
with the formula for compound V in the
comics the character is meant to be more
of a parody of the Shazam character from
DC in Thor from Marvel the tech Knight
character is meant to be sort of a
mash-up of Iron Man and Batman in the
comics he has a giant Batcave he makes
his own technology he doesn't have any
natural superpowers he uses his
technology to give him his abilities
obviously the trailer says it's going to
premiere next year but based on what
Karl Urban said when they wrapped
production a little while ago it's going to
premiere around the same time at the end
of July right around Comic Con just like
season 1 did there's a whole bunch of
other trailers coming this week and
obviously my Mandalorian episode 5 video
will post tomorrow so why you away for
everything click here for my brand new
Marvel Black Widow trailer in Easter
eggs and click here for all my other
boys season 2 teaser trailer videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!